you talked about reprogramming yourself
and that that old person was essentially
gone and there was a new person with new
thoughts is that common for people
especially filmmakers artists
no because most artists and people in
general we had doubt on ourselves we all
Own Worst Enemy we in our own way so I
was that person I was in my own way I
doubted myself insecurity depressed
because my life but then I realized that
Antoine you are enough
start reprogramming yourself and that's
all looking at other people like the
Tyler Perry reason I keep bringing that
name up Tyler Perry 50 Cent and the
Jay-Z's and even Steve Jobs
they did it they bet on theyself for me
all I need to see is one person do it
and then I'm good so once you got your
doubt engage yourself out the wig you
gotta realize that you know
no one no one is promised them all no
one promised them all so you having
doubts insecurities you're not the only
one
but don't let that stop you for going
after your dreams in life no matter what
it is if you want to be the best barber
hairstylist uh Soul designer person
whatever you want to do just try it just
try something fall in love with
something that's what I start to perform
in love with something because I
remember when I was young
I'd do anything for a girl I go crazy I
go to another state fall in love with
something once you fall in love with
something it's like it's a beautiful
thing but you know that gonna be there
but but do baby steps what I did was I
did the power yes
the things that I would never do I
started doing it
um a lot of people just call me an
introvert because I used to stay to
myself but I realized that Antoine you
gotta be your own cheerleader you gotta
speak for yourself you got to talk about
yourself how do you expect someone to
invest in you you want to invest in
yourself
have a conversations with yourself
um if you if you're going through
depression go to counseling like do
things that put yourself in a better
position that you was in yesterday it's
not going to happen overnight but start
the baby steps that's why I did start
little baby steps and eventually you're
gonna be the person you want to be
and
you we talked about this earlier and you
talked about this in power too that
there will be forces that will try to
yeah get you to go back to your old self
do you see that right away and certainly
like oh I know what this is right oh
yeah it's a setup so you see it like you
sometimes people bring their own trauma
on to you and then you gotta react so
what you got to do is you got to protect
your energy
if you know someone come in your life
like if I come to you with love and
respect and care and you come with the
opposite you're not ready to be over
here stay over there and I stay over
here because that old me gonna come out
you don't want that with me so you gotta
protect your energy it's no difference
in protecting your child we take it in
your house you got to protect your
energy because people will try to
interrupt your peace
and you know it's coming so you guys you
gotta do a good job I like thinking you
simplify I treat your life like a
security
if you have a house you get security
cameras you get a dog treat you like the
same way because peace and happiness is
oh man it's priceless
yeah
that's excellent excellent advice so
when someone came up to you
wherever or online and says that's not
fair how come you got this how come you
won this I said it's not fair that I was
homeless it's not fair that I had a
great parents life is not fair
but what you do is you can't control how
you start but you can't control how you
end your life so what I do is I create
the little world I want to create for
myself it's like X-Men you find your
mutants you find people that actually
get you
you don't have to try to fit in
everybody corner get your own tribe
that's what I learned dude I'm not for
everybody
I mean quiet taste
can you tell us more about your
self-doubt yeah I had a lot of
self-doubt
um being dachshund being a black man
watching films that I don't see my
people uh uh being in a neighborhood and
the cops call you the n-word
uh
just being an environment that you feel
like you're nothing
you know but then you realize that
those people rejecting their fears on
you
they're afraid
they they had their own demons inside
they done with so it's never you it's
the other person if you're comfortable
with peace and love and you come
opposite they broken don't take it
personal longer as long as they attack
your life for touching you let them be
but that's the way it is they broken
people broken her people hurt people and
pain see pain so that's why I had to
realize because I just take things
personally like why are you doing this
to me why are you saying negative things
to me oh I get it you're broken you need
a hug
and that's you got to realize that it's
never you it's the other person
even with the industry when someone says
oh you're probably not good enough it's
fine they told Sylvester Stallone the
same thing every story everybody got a
story that someone told them no and what
happens is no I mean not right now
and then when they come back to you
yesterday price is not today price
that's what you gotta do
and with Lola
does she have that surrounding her yeah
yeah so you got you know you got this
particular energy man like this industry
this life is not fair Cove is not fair
but we live in it and we're gonna make
it out of it but you really got to take
your energy
you really gotta protect the engine
because that peace of mind is priceless
and a lot of people went to depression
during covet and you know I lost some
people during covet I talked to people I
commit suicide during covet because it
was just too much because when covet
happened and you if you was going
through depression now you gotta be home
and look to have that person in the
mirror every day and some people like
what they see in the mirror so really
you know focus on your mental health and
um
get help if you need it but but check
your peace
and also too I'm not sure if covet makes
certain mental health issues worse to
anxiety and depression too so but take
your piece don't try to fit in with
everybody and everybody for you like I'm
a big believer protecting my peace if
you come in my life and being breaking
value and love and happiness you don't
need to be over here go back over there
with other happy people and you when you
get together come over here
so they'll unhappy people can have their
own parts right okay we up here having
fun enjoying life
yeah okay so you got to separate your
life man like we get one life that's it
can you think of any moments
even after you had reclaimed who you
wanted to be
where just certain things got to you and
you said enough is enough and I'm giving
up every day
but I realize that that's easy
I've been give up before people already
doubt me already so this is hard this is
not this is emotional rollercoaster but
when you protect your peace at very
point when you protect your piece you
can control the narrative in your life a
lot of times we're giving people power
that's not in your life you give them
your family power you give me your
friend power you give me this industry
power they tell you you're not good
enough
you gotta stop that
it's your life like no one you to see
all your life
you can high and fire yourself but if
you allow people to come in your life
and take your power
you're going to be depressed so for me I
had to realize that the answer and
you're giving people too much power take
that power back they have no power over
you and once I did that man
it was a blessing
and Lola takes back her power too yep
and is there one Catalyst character that
that changes that for her that makes her
take it back instead of being a victim
the person I remember
give a section that person America
always take your power back people
around you might inspire you but at the
end of the day when you go home it's you
and you have to do it like it saved me
like I'm always happy people know I'm
always happy joking around because I
realize that wait a minute
you are The Crazy Ones y'all are the
ones are getting I'm good I'm Healed so
just yeah except to take energy
I think in this industry there are a lot
of people that try to take your power
even if they don't mean to either
they're projecting their own thing onto
you but I think just knowing and I think
that's what stops a lot of artists from
wanting to go further is knowing that
there are these people that want to take
your power yeah those you know those are
the so-called Gatekeepers that feels
like they could prey on people that
don't have don't know their worth
daily everywhere then your family then
this industry that's your code job
you've had that boss at supervisor that
bought you for no reason like why are
you bothering me because they want to
feel in control
it's a control thing
but no one can control you unless you
give them the opportunity of the power
but yeah this is industry I learned that
I remember
Weiss's submit the festivals my first
feature and I still have it in my film
freeway account I got rejected by 95
film festivals
95 I know how much rejection you got to
be that 95 I saved I save all of them
but it's because
they can see the vision I can't get mad
at them at in the beginning yes I got
really mad like
I got mad because I was like damn I
can't get rejected rejected then I
realized Antoine
this is part of the journey you gotta
take the good with the bad the storm
don't last forever some will shine so
it's a journey
yeah all you need is that one yes like
this whole project will automatically
all you need is that one is you're gonna
get 100 no's well you need that one yes
and fresh that's gotta come from you
so with Lola one you probably got more
no's and then once you have that proof
of concept I got so many no's I got so
many knows that
I went to sleep dreaming my nose because
like I said when you do a project No One
Believes In and they tell you all the
extra stuff they don't make no sense it
happens but I'm built for this if I
could go through being homeless
going through all the stuff I went to
this is a piece of cake but you got to
know that
you know sometimes it reminds me
our goal is to look at other people's
stories I go on film coverage you have
tons of stories when I first started in
the film business I didn't have money go
to film school all this crazy stuff so I
went to film courage to educate myself
to look at filmmakers that was like me
that just needed some help
and yeah help me so it's just you know
you gotta realize that that no just a no
is not you
when you were laying in the bed with
covid and I don't know were you
hospitalized yeah I was in hospital you
were okay wow probably less but I was I
was so bad that I even remember going to
the hospital my wife took me that's how
bad I was like breathing trouble or what
was it I was dehydrated uh I had
headache back pains I was just
delusional it was really bad
so at any moment when you kind of came
to in the hospital did you say to
yourself if I make it out of here I want
to do a b and c yes so you were already
planning yeah so I already had my plan
but that hospital really pushed me also
too love you love your partner more
because sometimes we have friends and
family that we think that was going to
be there
and we don't really love them like we
should so I want to love it on people
way more that really appreciate me so my
wife she was there
um my friends family but yeah you gotta
love on people more because this was
crazy
and and so aside from the relationship
aspect did you say these are the goals I
want yes I said once I get out of here
I'm gonna go crazy that's why when covet
happened me and my rights got together
we not got like 50 trips I'm never
exaggerating I have my ideas if we're
gonna write a whole bunch of content so
next year I'm gonna flood the gates
because
yeah why not
did you see some people there the
hospital who didn't make it no but
everybody in that room had covet I was
standing room with someone that had
coveted but um it was just as bad then
when Kobe first happened in Queens
that's when they had the dead bodies in
the trunks in the Frieza I mean Frieza
so I see now on TV like it was just so
bad so it just it got motivate you like
sometimes we afraid but if if like you
gotta like I just had to wake up I was
doing great but Kobe made me put some
more pepper in my step yeah so you
already have these plans but then going
through that and being amazed
expeditiously like we gotta speed this
up
I'm I'm I'm wasting my time so yeah